and that image is kind of you know the  jeans the t-shirt yeah working guy image  you have it's interesting that when you  were a kid what you loved were kind of  the showman like Elvis and agar and all  of that I regret it to this day I've  never I've never looked good dressed up  ridiculous when I get really dressed up  you know always wanted the gold the may  suit and but no they never worked for me  but you did practice like Jagger moves  and stuff too well every every frontman  worth his salt has stood in front of a  mirror at some point in time with these  as a broom or the tennis racquet and  spent hours just moving to little 45s in  his room so yeah that was a big part of  my my studies  [Music]  you